Good
for decades,
ethnic groups have,
on average,
scored significantly differently on Iq
tests.
According to psychology professor
Richard Harris,
whom you interviewed on your channel
Youtube,
there was no scientific consensus on the
causes of these average differences in
Iq test scores.
Yet,
according to Haier,
psychologists do generally agree that
general intelligence exists that Iq
measures that well and in a non
culturally biased way that Iq is highly
predictive of success and educational
and professional terms and that for
decades,
ethnic groups have on average,
scored significantly differently.
So assuming this is true,
should we talk about it?
Sam Harris raised this question and a
podcast conversation with Charles
Murray.
Some argue that we should not talk about
this as doing so could fuel the racial
supremacist movements that you mentioned
with potentially horrific consequences.
Others mainly on the intellectual dark
web and to a very limited extent in
academia.
I think we should talk about this topic
because average differences in Iq scores
have existed for decades.
They may have played a role in
generating the disparate educational and
professional outcomes that we observe
and care about,
and thus that we cannot properly analyze
these disparate outcomes unless we do
talk about the subject openly.
Geneticists,
David Reich recently argued in the New
York Times that have scientists do not
openly discuss the biological basis of
race.
Pseudo scientists could fill the vacuum
with dangerous consequences.
Furthermore,
you,
Professor Peterson are highly critical
of the oppression narrative that
permeates segments of the academy and
activist left and knowledge about
average differences in Iq scores between
ethnic groups,
while tough to assimilate could puncture
this narrative.
So the question is,
what is your view on all that?
I've just said,
Jesus,
you guys already didn't take a long time
to prepare these questions.
Didn't know.
Alright,
so
when I went to Harvard,
I came from mcgill and I had spent a lot
of time with my advisor there and a
research team that he had trying to
understand the genesis of antisocial
behavior and him among adolescents,
mostly so well as kids as well.
It's antisocial behavior is very
persistent.
So if you have a child whose conduct
disordered at the age of four,
the probability that they will be
criminal at the age of 15 or 20 is
extremely high.
It's unbelievably stable.
It's a very dismal literature because
you see these early onset aggressive
kids and and it's persistent and then
you look at the intervention literature
and you throw up your hands because no
interventions work and believe me,
psychologists have tried everything you
could possibly imagine and a bunch of
things that you can't in order to
ameliorate that.
So we're really interested in trying to
understand,
for example,
if you're antisocial by the age of four,
then there isn't an intervention that
seems to be effective.
So,
and the standard penal logical theory is
really quite horrifying in this regard
because what you see is that male
aggression peaks around the age of 15
and then it declines fairly
precipitously and,
and,
and sort of normalizes again by the age
of 27.
And Standard penal logical theory
essentially is this cold hearted.
It's like if you have a mold,
if you have someone who is a multiple
offender,
you just throw them in prison til
they're 27,
then the age out of it,
and that's all there is to it.
That's what we've got.
Now,
there's some downside to that because
there's a corollary literature that
suggests that the worst thing that you
can do with antisocial people is to
group them together,
which is what we do in prisons.
So,
so that's a whole mess.
Anyways.
One of the things we were doing was
trying to see if there might be
cognitive predictors of antisocial
behavior.
And so we use this battery of
neuropsychological tests that was put
together at the Montreal Neurological
Institute,
took about 11 hours to administer and
hypothetically assessed prefrontal
cortical function.
We computerized that,
reduced it to about 90 minutes and then
assessed antisocial adolescents in
Montreal and found out that they did
show deficits in problem solving ability
that we were associated with,
uh,
with prefrontal ability.
Um,
when I got to Harvard,
I thought,
well,
that's interesting.
We could use the neuro psych battery to
predict negative behavior.
Perhaps we could use it to predict
positive behavior.
So I thought,
well,
what if we turned the neuro psych
battery and over and thought,
well,
can we predict grades,
for example,
because you know,
that's a decent thing to predict.
So we ran a study,
we ran a study that looked at Harvard
kids,
University of Toronto kids line workers
at a Milwaukee factory and managers and
executives at the same factory.
And what we found was that the average
score across these neuropsychological
tests,
they were kind of like games.
They were game like,
you know.
So in one,
in one test you had,
there were five lights in the middle of
the screen and a box was associated with
each light and you had to learn by trial
and error,
which box was associated with,
with each light.
That was one of the tests.
Um,
so we took people's average score across
the tests because they seem to clump
together into a single structure.
You can do,
you can find that out statistically.
If you take a bunch of tests,
you can find out how they clumped
together statistically by looking at
their patterns of correlations.
And you might get multiple clumps,
which is what happens with personality
research where you get five or you might
get a singular clump,
which is what happens.
Cognitive research.
And we got a single clump essentially.
And then we were trying to figure out if
at the same time I was reading the
literature on performance prediction and
there's an extensive literature on
performance prediction,
a lot of it generated by the armed
forces,
by the way,
I'm indicating that ICU is a very good
predictor of longterm life success.
And so here's the,
here's the general rule.
If your job is simple,
which means you do the same thing every
day than Iq predicts how fast you'll
learn the job,
but not how well you do it.
But if your job is complex,
which means that the demands change on
an ongoing basis,
then the best predictor of success is
general cognitive ability.
And uh,
and I learned that the general cognitive
ability tests clump together into a
single factor that's fluid intelligence
or Iq.
And then we didn't know if the factor
that we had found was the same factor as
Iq and it.
And we still haven't really figured out
whether or not that was the case because
it kind of depends on how you do the
analysis.
But anyways,
I got deeply into the performance
prediction literature and I found out,
well if you wanted to predict people's
performance in life,
there's,
there's a couple of things you need to
know.
You need to know their general cognitive
ability.
If they're going to do a complex job,
you need to know their trait.
Conscientiousness,
some of you might've heard that
rebranded as grit in a very corrupt act
by the way,
um,
because it's a good predictor of
longterm life success,
freedom from negative emotion.
Low neuroticism is another predictor,
but it's sort of third on the hierarchy.
And then openness to experience which is
a personality trait,
is associated with,
with expertise in creative domains.
The evidence that now I should tell you.
So it's such a complicated question.
I should tell you how to make an Iq
test.
It's actually really easy and you need
to know this to actually understand what
Iq is.
So imagine that you generated a,
a set of 10,000
questions about anything.
It could be math problems,
they could be general knowledge,
they could be vocabulary,
that could be multiple choice.
It really doesn't matter what they're
about as long as they require
abstraction to solve,
so they'd be formulated linguistically,
but mathematically would also apply.
And then you have those 10,000
questions.
Now you take a random set of 100 of
those questions and you give them to a
thousand people and all you do is sum up
the answers right from so some people
are going to get most of them right and
some of some of them are going to get
most of them wrong.
You just rank order the people in terms
of their score,
correct that for age and you have Iq.
That's all there is to it.
And what you'll find is that no matter
which random set of 100 questions you
take,
the people at the top of one random set
will be at the top of all the others and
it with very,
very,
very high consistency.
So one thing you need to know is that if
any social science claims whatsoever are
correct,
then the ICU claims are correct because
the ICU claims are more psychometrically
rigorous than any other phenomena
phenomena that's been discovered by
social scientists.
Now,
the ICU literature is a dismal
literature.
No one likes it.
Here's why.
Here's an example.
So here's a little,
here's a fun little fact for you,
for Liberals and conservatives alike,
because conservatives think there's a
job for everyone.
If people just get off their asses and
get the work and liberals think while
you can train anyone to do anything,
it's like,
no,
there isn't a job for everyone and no,
you can't train everyone to do
everything that's wrong.
And here's one of the consequences of
that.
So as I mentioned,
the Armed Forces has done a lot of work
on ICU when they started back in 19,
19.
And the reason they did that was
because,
well,
for obvious reasons,
say let's say there's a war and you want
to get qualified people into the officer
positions as rapidly as possible or
you'll lose.
So that's a reason.
Now,
the armed forces has experimented with
Iq tests since 19,
19,
and in the last 20 years I'm a law was
passed as a consequence of that
analysis,
which was that it was illegal to induct
anyone into the armed forces who had an
Iq of less than 83.
Now the question is why and the answer
was all of that effort put in by the
armed forces indicated that if you had
an Iq of 83 or less,
there wasn't anything that you could be
trained to do in the military that
wasn't positively counterproductive.
Now you got to think about that a,
because the military is chronically
desperate for people right there.
It's not like they're so like people are
lining up to be inducted,
right?
They have to go out and recruit and it's
not easy and so they're desperate to get
their hands on every body they can
possibly manage and then especially in
war time,
but also in peacetime.
But then there was another reason too,
which was the armed forces,
was also set up from a policy
perspective to take people in the
underclass,
let's say,
and train them and move them up at least
into the working class or maybe the
middle class.
So there's a policy element to it too.
And so even from that perspective,
you could see that the military is
desperate to bring people in,
but it well with an Iq of 83 or less,
it's not happening.
Okay?
So how many people have an Iq of 83 or
less?
Ten percent.
Now,
if that doesn't,
if that doesn't hurt you to hear,
then you didn't hear it properly.
Because what it implies is that in a
complex society like ours and one that's
becoming increasingly complex,
there isn't anything for 10 percent of
the population to do.
Alright,
well what are we going to do?
We're going to ignore that.
We're going to run away from that and
believe me,
we have every reason to.
Or we're going to contend with the fact
that we need to figure out how it is,
how it is,
how it might be possible to find a place
for people on the lower end of the
general cognitive distribution to take
their productive and worthwhile place in
society.
And that isn't just going to a matter of
dumping money down the hierarchy because
giving people who have nothing to do
money isn't helpful.
It doesn't work.
It's not that simple.
Well,
so that's kind of an answer to the
question of whether or not we should
deal with,
uh,
with Iq forthrightly.
It's like,
if you can find a flaw in that logic,
like just go right ahead.
It's not like I was thrilled to death to
discover all of this by nose,
by no stretch of the imagination.
Was that the case?
So,
so what?
So Iq is reliable and valid.
That's the first thing.
It's more reliable and valid than any
other psychometric test ever designed by
social scientists by a factor of about
three.
That's fact number one.
Fact number two is it predicts longterm
life outcome at about point three,
point four,
which leaves about 85 percent,
70 to 85 percent of the story
unexplained,
but it's still the best thing that we
have.
Well,
it's also the case that in places like
Great Britain,
when Iq tests were first introduced,
they were actually used by the
socialists and they were used to
identify poor people who had potential
cognitive potential and to move them
into higher Ed Institutes of higher
education.
So there's an upside,
you know,
social upside as well.
Ethnic differences.
This is something you can't say anything
about without without immediately being
killed.
So I'm hesitant to broach the topic,
but I'll tell you one thing that I did
in the last week that's relevant to
this.
So the,
and this just shows you how complex the
problem is.
First of all,
we should point out that race is a very
difficult thing to define because racial
boundaries aren't tight,
right?
So,
and so when you talk about racial
differences in Iq,
you,
you're faced with a thorny problem of
defining race.
And that's a big problem from a
scientific perspective,
but we'll leave that aside and I wrote
an article this week.
Somebody stood up at one point,
one of my talks and vice bless their
hearts,
took this particular question and used
it as an indication of the quality of
the people who are my so called
followers.
And by the way,
the quality of my so called followers is
pretty damn high.
And you can find that out quite rapidly
just by going looking at the youtube
comments which are head and shoulders
above what the standard set of youtube
comments.
I can tell you that.
So someone asked me that both the Jewish
question,
right?
And the,
the implication it was actually someone
Jewish and the implication was that Jews
are overrepresented in positions of
authority and power and,
and I was,
had just spoken for like an hour and a
half and you know,
this guy had an ax to grind and I
thought there is no God damn way I'm
getting into this at the moment.
And so I,
I said I'm.
I said,
I can't answer that question,
but that's not a very good answer.
So I wrote a blog post this week and I
said,
look,
here's the.
Here's the situation.
All right,
Jews are overrepresented in positions of
power and authority,
but then let's open our eyes a little
bit.
Hey,
thank for like two or three seconds and
think,
hey,
guess what?
They're also overrepresented in
positions of competence and it's not
like we have more geniuses.
Then we know what to do with and if the
Jews happened to be producing more of
them,
which they are,
by the way,
then that's a pretty good thing for the
rest of us.
So let's not confuse competence with
power and authority,
even though that's a favorite trick of
the radical leftists who always failed
to make that distinction.
Well,
why does this over representation occur?
Because it does it also.
There's also overrepresentation in
political movements including radical
political movements.
Okay,
why?
Well,
answer one Jewish conspiracy.
Okay.
That's not a very good answer.
We've had.
We've used that answer before.
Alright,
but,
but do we have an alternative?
Well,
here's an alternative.
The average Ashkenazi Iq is somewhere
between 1:10
and 1:15,
which is about one standard deviation
above the population average.
And so what that means is that the
average Ashkenazi Slash European Jew has
an Iq that's higher than 85 percent of
the population that's a lot higher now,
that doesn't make that much difference
in the middle of the distribution.
Okay?
But geniuses don't exist at the middle
of the distribution.
They exist at the tails of the
distribution and you don't need much of
a move at the mean to produce walloping
differences at the tails.
And the tails are important because a
lot of where we draw,
we draw exceptional people from the
exceptions.
Right?
So here's an example.
Here's another example of the same
thing.
Most engineers are male.
Why?
Because men are more interested in
things and women are more interested in
people and you might say,
well,
that's socio-cultural.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
And we know that because if you stack up
countries by their,
by their egalitarian social policies,
which you can do quite effectively.
And then you look at the
overrepresentation of men in stem
fields,
the overrepresentation increases as the
countries become more egalitarian.
So it's not socio-cultural.
Okay,
now men aren't that much more interested
in things than women.
It's one standard deviation,
which is about the same difference by
the way,
between the population norm in the
Ashkenazi Jews.
But if you're looking at the person who
the one person in 20 or the one person
in 50 who's most who's hyper interested
in things and that's likely to become an
engineer,
then most of them are men.
Here's another example of the same
thing.
Men are more aggressive than women.
Now you might ask how much and the
answer to that is best place to look at
that as in Sweden,
where the egalitarian policies of be
laid out for a long period of time and
you can.
You can get a more direct inference
about biology.
If you took a random man and a random
woman out of the population and you had
to bet on who was more aggressive and
you bet on the man you'd be right 60
percent of the time.
So that's not that much,
right?
It's,
it's deviates from 50 slash 50,
but it's not like 90 slash 10.
It's 60 40.
Okay.
So,
so what does that mean?
Well,
we got a tail problem here.
Again,
let's say that now you decide to go out
onto the extremes of aggression and you
identify the most aggressive one in 100
persons.
They're all men.
Guess who's in prison?
Those people.
That's why most of the people in prison
are men.
And so this is elementary part of the
problem in our society is that we don't
understand statistics.
We don't understand that you can have
relatively small differences at the
population level that produce walloping
consequences at the tails of the
distribution.
Okay.
So back to ICU.
One final thing to say about Iq.
The ethnic differences are difficult to
dispense with.
It's not easy to make them go away.
You can say,
well the tests aren't culture fair.
Well here's the test of that.
So imagine you,
you test group a with an Iq test and the
test group B with an Iq test and then
you look at their actual performance in
whatever you're predicting.
If the test was biased against ethnic
group A,
then it would under predict their
performance and that doesn't happen.
Now you could say,
well,
there's systemic bias in the performance
measures and the potential measures and
that's a possibility.
All right.
Now one other thing about that.
There's a real danger in the ethnicity
Iq debate and the danger is that we
confuse intelligence with value or that
we include we we confuse intelligence
with yet with human value.
That's a better way of thinking about it
and one of the things that we're going
to have to understand here is that
that's a mistake,
is that being more intelligent doesn't
make you a better person.
That's not the case.
It makes you more useful for complex
cognitive operations,
but you can be pretty damn horrific as a
genius son of a bitch,
right?
It's morally neutral,
and we also know that from the
psychometric data.
By the way,
there doesn't seem to be any
relationship whatsoever between
intelligence and virtue,
and so if it does turn out that nature
and the fates do not align with our
egalitarianism presuppositions,
which is highly probable.
We shouldn't therefore make the mistake
of assuming that if group A or person a
is lower on one of these attributes than
group B or person b,
that that is somehow reflective of their
intrinsic value as human beings.
That's a big mistake.